he's a gloater I get it but it's the age
of outrage and this is like what we're
seeing from this Roseann stuff look dude
I've been called a racist more times
over the last few days for defending
Roseann oh I'm saying that I know her
she's mentally ill and she's on all
kinds of pills I don't think she's a
racist I listen I'm gonna say this too I
think that this is a just because you
can doesn't mean you should situation
can I tweet something inappropriate of
course you can should you when you have
all of this things that you're
responsible for sure you're the lead of
a show you you're you know it's a show a
family show you're on a family network
you have a lot of people's jobs that are
depending on you and I think there was
just a error in judgment Oh 100% I do I
think that she's a racist I think that I
think that if she had just called the
woman just ugly she and and talked about
her her job what would this have been
the same thing but you you add you know
it's like if you call somebody a [ __ ]
okay there's a problem you people can
have a problem with that you call
somebody a black [ __ ] and all of a
sudden that changes it no yeah if you
call somebody a black monkey [ __ ] then
you're like okay where's this coming
from
well perfect example is Samantha be
calling Ivanka Trump a feckless [ __ ] and
she said it on TV
she's something that was prepared like
someone wrote that out there's a part of
her monologue she said it on television
and then they apologize so I shoulda
said it and they're the end TBS's like
we're good but the advertisers are not
good they're pulling out left and right
but here's the thing with Roseanne she's
not well this is a fact like I know I've
talked to her she's told me I've talked
to other people who know her I talked to
people who worked with her she's
mentally ill but it talks openly about
it
hold on a second she's on a host of
medications she's on antidepressants
she's on ambien she's drinking she's
smoking pot she's 66 years old she's not
she's not well she smoked cigarettes
she's out of it like she's got real
mental
shoes now here's the thing if she had
problems with her lungs and she was
smoking cigarettes and coughing up blood
what would and and doing stupid [ __ ]
like trying to run marathons would
people go hey you know what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you
you know you think you could run a
marathon what do you would you were you
[ __ ] stupid
no they wouldn't because they're go
she's got an illness this is why she
can't run this is why she's coughing up
blood she's got a mental illness she's
mentally ill this is a fact that's why
she's on so many different medications
but she says mental illness what if you
were starting to get mentally ill are
you saying that like saying like sort of
overtly racist things first of all she
didn't know that lady was black that if
you've seen that woman she does not look
black
she thought that lady was Jewish when
she said plan of the AAP she said it
because of her haircut cuz she looks
like that lady from the Planet of the
Apes
she swear she swears and she swear to me
on the phone this exact word she goes I
would never [ __ ] say that you think
I'm so stupid that I would call black
lady plan of the Apes because I thought
she was Jewish she goes look at her she
doesn't look black oh that makes it okay
she's it doesn't but she's she's Jewish
too I mean those other things someone
said but look she did this she dressed
up like Hitler and had Jew cookies and
she was baking him back in the day yes
she's a [ __ ] stirrer by the way she's
also Jewish you know I think she gets a
free pass on doing that but I think that
when you make a mistake this is what's
missing from our society now she made a
mistake you should be allowed to
apologize for that mistake right live
with the shame and then you move on but
what we're trying to do now is remove
people yes some society altogether like
I don't want to like sit I'm not gonna
exist we're not gonna excuse her
behavior we're not even gonna say that
there's you know a reason even whatever
the reason is all the mental illness and
all this kind of stuff it's still a
mistake what happened she's well enough
to work on a television show
so I'm saying she made this mistake and
I'm not with I'm not with saying that
she's a racist either because when I
even when I read that I thought it I
don't I'm just saying as a comic we say
things that a regular person is gonna
translate the math into like well this
is because you don't like black people
are women or you don't like Jews or you
don't like that
how we operate just trying to be fun we
just trying to be funny and I think that
she comes from an era where this is what
you would say to be funny and biting
yeah and that thinking when she looked
back on it she went oh I didn't know
this person was black
now the people out there listening you
could believe it or not but at the same
time the Susan Rice comment from a long
time ago is way worse because she Susan
Rice is clearly black and she did a
comment a long time ago I think it was
like 2013 but she said Susan Rice is a
man with giant swinging 8 balls that's
what she said now that is way worse
that's way worse and that is a woman
who's clearly black I mean you look at
Susan Rice there's she's not racially
ambiguous at all this other woman
Valerie I don't know her name Jarrett
she's she's got straight hair she's got
light complexion she's a film it's all
about intent though what you're talking
about right but it's it's her intent was
to be funny she is obviously not doing
but first of all she was drunk and on
ambien and ambien is a class Hamilton
Morris sent me an email about this he
was explaining it to me and then I
talked to a sleep therapist about it
there there's a type of drug that ambien
is that's called a hypnotic and this is
one of the reasons why ambien has so
many weird side effects associated with
it um my friend Kevin James Kevin James
got up in the middle of the night cooked
a meal went to bed got up in the morning
and he had like his wife I confronted
him like did you do that he's I didn't
[ __ ] do that
and she's like no the food's in the
trash like you cooked it you ate it he's
like I did not I did not eat that and
she's like ok if you didn't do it who
did and like he had to like come to
grips of the fact that he was on ambien
he got up cooked a meal for himself had
no recollection of it went back to sleep
my mom was on ambien she got up in the
middle of the night and drew on the shag
carpet she had a white shag carpet in
her bathroom with lipstick and with with
nail polish like a little kid she was I
don't remember doing it at all
she this it's scary [ __ ] I know a bunch
of people that have had weird
experiences on that stuff but if you
staying at somebody's house and you
we're on ambien and you messed up their
shag carpet you'd apologize that's to
apologize for it but this is what I'm
saying that maybe sage she's also she's
also drunk on antidepressants which
you're not supposed to be and then she's
smoking pot which I'm sure you're
probably not supposed to do either when
you're on those things and she's an
older lady who just got off of an
exhausting schedule that almost she in
her words almost killed her she was she
had bronchitis when she was filming I'm
saying she's not doing well
she made a [ __ ] up mistake and she
apologized but everybody wants to bury
her right and that and I'm not with that
I don't Lu with you it's like you can't
that modesties society that we live in
right now that's just like a washing up
outrage right now but not just outrage
but we want to end your career yeah
like why do we want to end someone's
career for [ __ ] up like it's one
thing like here's the thing like if she
was not mentally ill there was nothing
wrong with her like say if someone from
let's just pick a sitcom theory you know
let's say the guy first on Stevie Stevie
Stella what's on TV right now this is
Davey yeah yes on CBS or just it's a new
one that's on TV what's a new one like
what's its Big Bang Theory song oh it is
okay all right Big Bang Theory if what
that / is a pretty blonde girl in the
Big Bang Theory oh yeah what if that
girl gets on TV and she's or she gets on
Twitter and she says something totally
racist throw some n bombs you know like
and there's nothing wrong with her she's
like this is just how I feel and then
they come after and they go well [ __ ]
this [ __ ] she shouldn't be on
television she's racist she doesn't
represent how America views people in
2018 she's archaic get her off the
[ __ ] air this is but this is you
can't get away with this any more this
is a 1920s this is 2018 that would be
acceptable I understand that if you
found a real hateful person she secretly
has like a swastika tattoo somewhere and
she's she's an evil person this is not
the case with Roseanne there's just not
it's just not the case she's an older
lady who's mentally disturbed and on a
[ __ ] host of competing medications
for her consciousness
well that should be the reason why she
needs help yeah we got to get her some
help
but he's a crazy thing is like she was
America's Sweetheart just a couple of
weeks ago I know that's how everybody
hates it's how quickly and people are
calling me a racist for saying what I
said right there this is not this is not
an unusual thing in our society like we
disco this is this very much reminds me
of the Salem witch hunt you know this is
the same kind of thing a little bit
right you know it's like The Scarlet
Letter like how old it is The Scarlet
Letter and we're still doing that
McCarthyism yeah this is something that
we're prone to it